what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are in Chicago we are gonna be
talking about sustainability and the
importance of progressing earth we are
with Steven cutter thanks for having me
thanks for coming on the show brother
and so let's start let's start by
unpacking kinda you know you're found it
you have founder of ug Muji's doing a
bunch of different things including
regenerative ride-sharing you have your
own coin regeneration hubs and all
towards sustainability of Earth and the
regeneration of earth's ecosystem and
just humans living harmoniously with
earth and the importance of that
so we'll get to unpacking wuji why did
you find sustainability and regeneration
of earth as this way for you to unleash
your soul into our world numerous
reasons it first started probably about
seven years ago I wasn't always driven
by sustainability or being in harmony
with the earth I even had a I had a
pipeline supply business that sold
consumable materials to contractors for
about four years prior to I have been
kind of a light switch go off and I can
give credit to a handful of people we
moved back to Chicago from Pennsylvania
and mine my sister didn't have cable and
his first time my life we didn't have
cable and I didn't realize how much
messaging was being you know put on us
through these commercials and I made my
kids at the time watch a documentary
before they could watch cartoon and you
watch things on volcanoes and the oceans
and anything kind of natural wildlife we
could find and I was just blown away by
all the different things I didn't know
about this you know beautiful earth and
what an incredible parenting tip prior
to watching cartoon you got to watch a
documentary yeah that's kind of that's
that's a good way to get some knowledge
in your kid at a young yeah and know my
kids I think probably know more about
the earth and then
most kids and this stemmed you know
curiosity from from myself just in
general about life and philosophy and
economics and you know it all revolved
around our earth it's our home you know
and the more and more I researched about
I planned it the more I wanted to do my
part to to make it a better place and
that's kind of where it all started so
as you're researching and understanding
more about our planet and wanting to do
your share and making it a better place
then how did you land on wuji by
accident literally I was driving the
toyota echo at the time and i I crashed
it I was looking at a flower while I was
driving and the guy in front of me
didn't put on his blinker and I asked
hold him sorry the language and then I
needed a new car and my sister gave me
your old minivan and I started doing
rideshare and I've always been an
entrepreneur and I write when I started
doing write sure I realized there was no
green option there was no option I felt
that trait treated the drivers fairly
and I've never been in tact before and I
just dove right in and created a pitch
deck and financials and one-pager and
went to events and started to pitch in
to investors and got some interest right
away and you know I had a couple mentors
along the way coached me and and and
still getting coached you know I think
that's one of the great lessons I've
learned is you know always be humble and
learn from people that have done before
and learn from their mistakes and learn
from the things they've done well and so
from there I I me you know I used my my
intuition my creativity just come up
with ideas and how the right circuit
actually be an education vehicle for for
the public you got a intimate setting
and if we can help curb their their
knowledge and break down ignorance and
show most importantly solutions I think
is you know why one of the reasons
climate change and
in action is still stagnant is that when
you get told there's 400 parts per
million of carbon in the atmosphere and
what do you what are you gonna do about
that do you have any options in your own
life to make it change some plant some
trees so that's one of the things that
we're gonna be doing is a given solution
so every ride that people take a little
5% of it will go back towards
regenerative actions planting trees
cleaning up the oceans giving someone
access to clean drinking water and then
also will have the communities be able
to nominate projects in their own
community that funds will go towards as
well okay so we got lucky we evolved on
this earth and we have consciousness and
we're able to build buildings and
cameras and all this interesting [ __ ]
and we are not really building
harmoniously with Earth's natural
ecosystem in a lot of ways we are not
and so with this inspiration to figure
out how to build harmoniously you were
like why is there no green ride-sharing
option and why can't I do that and then
it started with the deck and the
financials and getting investor interest
and so then as you're building this out
you're thinking about the different ways
that you can give back so this is pretty
simple on my phone rather than uber or
lyft I'm selecting Mooji Mooji has let's
say a plethora of cars available in
Chicago for me to take now the benefit
of doing it is that I get hopefully same
price ride and I get to have 5% of that
ride go towards sustainable action
regenerative action and that means
planting trees are clean drinking water
for people and then also a more fair
system for the driver to be an owner in
what they're building and the customer
to also be an owner and what they're
building you were teaching me about this
interesting like residual structure that
is made also from it that I can get
other people to get on board as drivers
and as
passengers and we there's a percentage
share system that comes from that and
yeah teach us about well if you look at
the economics in the world right now
there's a handful of people who have the
majority of money people have about 50
percent yeah yeah and I don't think
that's a fair system and I think in this
world as part of like my spiritual
journey as well is we have too much
ownership too much attachment to our
ideas even you know this idea is not
mine you know I'm sure of thousands of
people thought of creating a green right
it's your company I'm just the one
that's you know pursuing it and so
interesting it's like an oh it's like an
ocean of ideas that like come through
the human and out into the world through
the human and like you said it's more
about the lasting impact of the idea
than it is about yeah the person yeah so
I don't have ownership over any of this
I want to create solutions that that can
leave a lasting impact and if I only
hold the idea and I try to make it all
mine then you know then what's the point
you know I'm not doing this for myself
you know I'm doing this for everyone and
you meant create systems of giving and
so drivers will be owners in the
business it's gonna be more of a
cooperative model so does that look like
well initially I had told the investors
that the drivers owned only 25 percent
because they didn't even like hearing
that
you know some investors would say how's
that can affect my return they said well
how it's gonna affect your return it's
no different if we're gonna have drivers
be the investors in the business and own
it or if we have a couple of people you
know I'd rather have many people get the
benefits of ownership rather than the
people that already have the money and
I've had a battle with the venture
capital world on a philosophical level
and even going through this it's it's
four times as hard to raise money for
social impact than it is for a regular
business and in my mind that's crazy you
know like
four times it should be the opposite and
that's kind of one of my goals is to to
flip you know the venture capital model
on his head in flipped currency on its
head on that matter as well so it'll be
more of a cooperative model and we're
still fine-tuning that we're looking to
launch it in the end of the summer in
Minnesota my home state as born in st.
Paul and that's where we're looking to
launch it shout out to our homies in
Minnesota and it's a group called one
Minnesota it's a community development
group that focuses on shared equity
models and yeah it's kind of perfect
that a group that's focused on shared
equity and community development is
gonna be the one launching it cuz I've
been pitching to investors for two years
and they all told me I was crazy to
think I could compete with you know
Hoover and lift and little price me out
of the market and they'll just copy it
and put a green button on but they can't
copy drivers have any ownership in the
business they they can't copy being a
benefit court but I can't copy the
residual income factor so with the
residual income anyone that gets a
writer a driver signed up they'll get a
commission of every ride that's taken
it's a pretty powerful system when you
look at the average person spends
fifteen hundred dollars a year in ride
share now if you get a thousand people
to sign up and each one spends fifteen
hundred dollars and you get a one or two
percent of then it becomes pretty
powerful and we can do this with the
University students you know there's a
I've talked a lot of the brand
ambassadors for other rights Romano's
where they just pass out promotional
material on the streets they get roughly
200 a week to download the app so you do
the math you can get you know ten
thousand people signed up in under six
months
working in under 25 hours a week and
they can go to festivals they can go to
you know the zoo they can go to like
cool areas and just walk around and and
spread the word and that's one of our
main marketing tactics is more organic
we
the people - you want to invest the
marketing and advertising dollars into
the people rather than and ads created
by Facebook and so we even looked to
have drivers who wanna like create
videos and content and then if they put
that out there and they get downloads
from it they'll will get Commission's
from from that so getting creative and
and sharing it's kind of the focus and I
mean we can't have our own marketing and
an advertising budget and have 10 people
20 people kind of try to come up with
ideas or we can we can put it out there
to thousands of people and say you know
create something and give them the value
for creating it so what does it look
like out of the ride that would happen
first of all it's really important that
there are lots of wuji drivers that are
on the road because people love
convenience so if it only takes me five
minutes to get an uber or lyft like I
would really like it to only be five
minutes also to get somebody from muji
so when it launches in Minneapolis st.
Paul and it launches there that it'd be
great if it was you know same timing
that would be so awesome if there was
like a couple hundred drivers that were
on the road the first day that would be
fantastic
but now okay so let's say that I take a
$15 ride or $20 ride from Saint Paul to
Minneapolis or something so 5% of that
goes to sustainable over generations and
then one or two percent of that would go
to the person that signed me up hmm okay
so there's 93% left now how much does
the driver get you approx no or yeah the
drivers gonna get roughly the same
amount as the current right sure drivers
are getting 70 percent is what they get
they say it's it's 80 percent but when
they they they take out the deductions
for prior to
the drivers compensation so depending on
the length of the ride and the
Commission it could be only 50 percent
so if it's only like a seven dollar ride
they take that to 50 like charge off the
top for the insurance and the safety for
whatever they call it and then then they
get then they get the cut from the five
dollars so they're actually on the on
the shorter rides are getting less than
like right around 50 percent and longer
rides they make they make the 70 percent
80 percent but our benefits more coming
these long-term lasting rewards not just
a residual income but the equity options
and we have other revenue models for our
drivers as well and you guys perm grow
the business of wuji the B Corp with the
rest of the so if they would a driver
gets eighty percent and then the there's
only 13 percent left then you would take
the as the B Corp to grow the B Corp
yeah yeah okay and but then one of the
things you mentioned is convenience and
that's one of the other things I
realized is why we are where we are as
far as our climate no one wants to be
inconvenienced to do anything you know
recycling you know no one wants to take
an extra step that their the recycling
thing away and so you have to make it as
convenient as possible for people to
make change because if someone has to
spend any more money or take more time
or any more efforts it's less likely
that they're gonna do it so the whole
goal with this is to be as convenient as
is anything you don't have to think
about doing an action and it'll be doing
every genitive you know concept so
that's the whole goal with everything
that I'm working on and said you don't
have to think about what you're doing
and that actions gonna do something good
okay the convenience factor is totally
there then if I don't even have to think
about it twice and all good things are
happening okay so there's also a
regenerative regenerative aspect to both
the ride-sharing and then there is also
a coin there's a Wu Jie a Wu Jie as a
coin hmm so what is the idea behind this
I plant a tree yeah I get a coin yeah
yeah okay so I was turned down to a
principle called natural capital
accounting about a year ago natural
capital accounting yep through one of my
partners the earth dollar which I'm a
board member of the earth dollar earth
dollar yeah shout out to David Camm and
the earth dollar but their principle is
they have 40 million acres of indigenous
and sovereign land backing their
currency and the more you improved the
land the the more the currency is worth
and this natural capital counting
principle has been a study for about 25
years to the UN and the World Bank and
many you know top universities in the
world and it puts a value on the living
ecosystem so getting in the blockchain
and more and more blockchain partners
and you can't go anywhere with someone
not mentioning blockchain now one of my
partners put put on an event that the UN
General Assembly that we went to for the
sustainable development goals and then
from that she got invited to throw an
event at the World Economic Forum and
then she decided she want to do a
hackathon in five weeks she put on a
hackathon at the World Economic Forum
and she invited in mean that and I put
together a team and we started off with
an idea where you could play a game like
similar to Sim City but you'd be growing
a forest and you get education around
you know what your actions are actually
doing so when you grow out your forest
you learn about the animals that are
going to be there and
all the other different biodiversity and
and then it actually by playing that
game the data and ads and the the the
inputs that would go in from a player
playing the game would actually
contribute towards planting a tree so
trying to take like the the digital
world and make a physical action just by
playing the game or you take grow your
forest take care of it the more trees
get planted in the real world yeah yeah
and from that we had about three
different conversations on the game idea
and we're still gonna be building that
game at a hackathon this summer in
Chicago at Navy Pier with the Chicago
blockchain project August 24th and 25th
but so from there we just said can we
just create a platform where it tracks
trees being planted the tracks their GPS
location who planted it the time the
date what type of tree and then from
that information we can give these
natural capital assets out and that's
what we built so we went there I mean we
both out a platform that that tracks
these regenerative acts and gives people
rewards for doing so and that's the one
of the main things I like about
blockchain is you can create a value
system around a currency and so far your
system works right we'll just create a
whole new economy we're taking care of
the earth we'll provide all the physical
abundance we need oxygen you know and
the sequester all the carbon create
biodiversity purify the water but also
the digital currency needed to be traded
because the only reason currency was
trading or was created was because they
couldn't keep track of the trading
anymore it got too big and the camel of
the calculators that they had you know
we're on I figured what the name that's
a call but they had like the you slide
them over that's what they were tracking
it with so they created a currency to
track it now about 60% of our currency
is digital anyways so
this is a system where we can we can
give incentives and values around taking
care of our home which should be the
greatest importance yes and you know I'm
uh
I've been called insanely optimistic you
know and I like that and I don't think
it's that it's that hard to think of a
world where cleaning up our mess can
create and this amount of jobs it can
there's so much jobs we can create an in
science and you know in in health care
and and you can end poverty by taking
care of the earth now and I see a great
future around that we're very blessed to
have optimistic and ambitious people
like you pursuing this and we care so
much about sustainability as well we
speak a lot about it we host a lot of
people that we help amplify the voices
about it something that you said that I
think is really important is that you're
helping with the educate oh by the way
we have we have tea bowls of bowls of
tea by the way Cheers
okay we get the education of the child
because they get to play this set of
sneeze yeah
salud yeah I can tell it might've been a
cough so the child gets to play the game
which is awesome because they get to
immerse themselves in a digital yeah and
or adults exactly but especially
children because we're trying to help
form their mind at young ages to
understand the connectivity we have to
our planet okay so boom so the kids
playing it their minds being expanded
they realize more of the connectivity
earth then the actions that they take in
the game and the sustainability that
they foster in the game helps then send
you guys data about their success then
you guys go and plant trees with that
now as you plant trees you have the C
type so the tree type you have the
geographical coordinates of where you
planted it and you have the person's
name that planted it and then the
general idea becomes that you have a
ledger over time and decentralized
distributed digital ledger over time
that will then indicate the sustainable
growth that has happened across the
regenerative growth that has happened so
that's huge okay now now what happens
when I get would G so I have woozi now
I've played the game or I've I've gotten
from what are the ways to get wuji and
then what can I do with the wuji so
there's there's about four different
phases and four different ways to to
receive a token one you can simply
contribute and pay to plant a tree then
once that tree is planted and then
you'll get the confirmation of that
digital asset and then from there the
the longer the tree live is the
valuable and more valuable creates those
reoccurring tokenization over time yeah
so we're not creating the
supply-and-demand there's not gonna be a
billion and you can you know mint yours
and there's not gonna be any mining they
only get created after the action is
completed there's gonna be on unlimited
amounts of coin yeah okay so if one of
the first ways to participate is to pay
to play I go by tree seeds yeah and then
or I can go to the forest and go collect
and then go and replant well yeah
initially we're we're gonna work with
the tree planting partners global NGOs
have been planting trees for four years
one of the first trees we're gonna start
planting and work with our mangroves and
working with Eden projects why mangrove
trees when you look at a mangrove tree
and all it provides it's one of the most
beneficial tree we can plant on the
earth helps aquatic life marine life and
also the life on land and they're a very
fast-growing tree and they they don't
need a lot of maintenance they can grow
pretty rapidly and actually after you
plant mangrove tree within five years
that that forest will reproduce over
2,000 percent so it's of itself so it
produces enough it gets some maturity
quickly and it releases more seeds than
get planted and within five years that
it's over 2,000 percent of what it was
okay so you partner with other world
leading tree planting organizations and
then you help bring them the
infrastructure that's needed for them to
log on the digital Ledger over time and
then also you give them
wuji for them planting and then now they
have let's say thousands or hundreds of
thousands of wuji and then the value of
that wuji today would need to be
translated into like a US dollar or
something so how would that work I mean
just like any other digital currency how
you can exchange it for Fiat or we're
setting up other partnerships with
businesses so the phase one is you just
pay to to plant a tree some
exchange them no for for wuji for the
coin would be on an exchange we're still
debating on if we're gonna have an
exchange and if you can exchange if with
other tokens or Oh or just a Fiat
yeah yeah but so first is an individual
can pay but we're also looking for
businesses business is already off are
offsetting their carbon footprints and
they do do that with tree planting
primarily so now we can go to companies
that have to offset their footprint and
say hey not only can you do this action
in before it was just a cost to them or
a tax write-off
now it'll create them lasting value so
it's not a tough sell for to get these
large corporations to to buy into this
one of my partner's is with the good
karma movement Sarah Maxwell and she
specializes in partnerships and PR with
good karma brands and so we're putting
it to Patagonia and Clif Bar and and
then we're creating this partner Network
so imagine if you're you know Clif Bar
and you wanna with every box of Clif
bars sold you'd plant a tree
you would get a tax write-off you get to
boost your social and environmental
impact marketing and then you get a
loyalty system for your members to keep
coming back so that's like you get a
wuji coin yeah that's the loyalty system
yeah yeah yeah yeah so they keep coming
back and then we'll set up other partner
businesses to be able to exchange it
with so similar like credit card miles
you know like you can you know get a
trip you can buy golf clubs you can you
know buy food you know whatever whatever
networks we set up and then a third way
we look think it'd be very simple and
beneficial is to create got pension fund
so imagine if you could put in a hundred
million dollars towards planting trees
which would plant about a billion trees
and the average stream roughly over the
course of its life will produce around
fifteen hundred dollars worth of these
natural capital assets so when you look
at an investment of anywhere from ten
cents to a dollar
you get $1,500 in return that 15 doesn't
go in your pocket the 15 years agos into
the sustainability of the planet yeah
yeah so it's actually literally
investing into the future of the planet
investing into the world that we're
leaving children yeah damn so yeah we
have the the businesses that can
contribute we have the pension fund and
then with all this we're looking to
create in any of the game as well and
then we're looking to create these
impacts these regenerative impact hubs
in nature because we're gonna be
planting a lot of trees and I'm an
entrepreneur and I like to foster other
people's ideas and share ideas with with
as many people as we can so imagine like
we work in an accelerator in the Amazon
and you go stay there and work on your
startup idea in in the mean time you
plant trees and clean the water and you
know improve the land screw your own
food and that would be your job and by
just planting trees it would provide you
of all the money you would ever need so
you won't need to get a job working for
somebody else just to create some other
financial return for the top eight
people on the planet you can spend your
time working on your passions and your
hobbies and we help foster and grow and
innovate and and then just by doing the
actions towards the earth would provide
you both the physical and and digital
abundance that you would need okay so
this is a regenerative impact hub so
this is like a green version of we work
or a green version of Google that's
baked into nature yeah and so then
there's all these awesome people that
are coming out there to do things like
collaborate and create and live on the
land also to you know whether
temporarily or permanently live on a
land also to have garden ecosystems for
food and energy and then what you're
doing then is you're planting trees and
you're earning wuji and
wuji is then sustaining the impact of
the regeneration impact up over time
okay so then it's a combination of those
impact hubs the Mooji the coin itself
getting corporations the game and then
the rideshare yeah so it's kind of a big
there's a lot going on in this puzzle
yeah of sustainable regeneration yeah
yeah yeah I mean I have a lot of people
were kind shin fund
yeah yeah yeah I have a lot of people
working on it with me
you know that's it's one of the main
things I really found initially when I
got into this tech entrepreneur world is
that in the impact world well there
there's not a lot of venture capital
money for it there's a lot of
collaboration people we're all working
towards the same goal like you said it'd
be pretty easy to get a Clif Bar on
board or something like this yeah so
yeah it's a it's not competition in in
the traditional business it's all about
competition and in signing NDA's and
being secretive and you know I I've only
found collaboration in the impact space
and blockchains another level of that
watching community is very open source
and collaborative and in greentech
Orient's sustainability or anything yeah
me up so I have a large network that's
that's working on all these things for
me and I'm just kind of putting all the
pieces together and sharing the ideas
and when they stick they stick and and
then you just run with them I like how
we were it's good that you have a
massive team I love that I've really
dedicated and also you like you said
diverse across blockchain as well as
companies like Patagonia or Clif Bar now
this is really important especially
because of what world we're passing down
to our children and children being
educated about the harmony that humans
have with nature that were not different
we are the same as nature we are one on
the plan and with nature
so the question about sustainability
then becomes good okay we got your
project we got all these good things
that were doing but the whole idea of
consciousness expansion like opening up
people's minds these new dimensions of
thought about the oneness and the
sustainability it's it's a it's kind of
a difficult Trek to to get people to go
on like the best I think that I heard
from you so far is that you got the
sustainable game that people can play
regenerative game they can participate
in this economy that you're creating
that way it's you know it requires even
less action for them but they can just
participate in it passively in this
economy what their normal everyday
habits so how what what else are we
looking at that needs to happen in order
like I mean you're doing so many good
things but I'm just so it's so difficult
to get people to to get into the full
rhythm of walking that extra mile or
doing that extra thing or not hopefully
not doing that extra thing soon but but
yeah tell us a little bit more about
just like the importance of the
sustainable effort and how we can
actually get there with you and with
more than you well you started that
segment with with kids and I think
throughout my history of trying to share
this information and educate my friends
and family that the older you get with
with trying to share this information
the more closed off they are so I think
it is very important to focus on on the
childress because the youth they're
gonna steer the ship you know and one of
my partner's is also with the give token
they teach children the power of giving
both from the spiritual sense but also
how when you give you receive and they
have like over five million children and
their network and they have plans to get
two billion children in the
their network what's the gift so they
teach children financial literacy and
also ongoing education but it all starts
with a place from giving so they want us
to be one of the first things the
children can give to to produce this
return over the you know like tree
planting kits yeah yep yep oh that's a
that's another group as well that yeah
that's I am alive in a week they have
ten million children in their network
they give tree planting kits and music
kits to that will they'll also be able
to use the the wuji coin to be able to
track and to give rewards give me more
hope by talking about kids you do you
give me more hope when when we when we
talk about kids and tree planting kits
and educational infrastructure for kids
to grasp onto the regeneration yeah yeah
and I mean just now realizing through
this conversation that when I first got
into sustainability I thought it was the
the most important thing to to teach
children and I wanted to teach gardening
to children at schools and I didn't know
how to garden so I went and garden for
two years I didn't end up putting that
business together schools are pretty
bureaucratic Kimball musk is doing yeah
actually I met him at the World Economic
Forum and I didn't know his name I just
knew he was the food guy I said hey
you're the food guy yeah and he's like
yeah that's me and I got his email and I
emailed him like four times he doesn't
got backed me in but maybe I'll keep
doing it maybe this interview will help
yeah just definitely get Kimball to care
more about wuji because I think they're
very synergistic yeah ya know I think
for me it the my path on sustainability
it was it was really all about the food
you know if you control the seed you
control the population
I think Kissinger said that yeah yeah
and in our food system is not healthy
right now there's more high fructose
corn syrup and then there is like
nutrition and the majority of the food
we eat
insult processed food chemicals you know
dyes additives and if you don't have a
healthy body it's very hard to have a
healthy mind so the I think it really
starts with the food in the earth you
know see yeah yeah and I just actually
just heard an interesting study about
the Corn Belt in the United States and
I'm not a big fan of corn you know they
say corn can feed the world but we feed
corn to animals which animals take up
way more resources and now one of the
biggest contributors to climate change
but the the Corn Belt produces as much
oxygen as the Amazon rainforest is what
I heard a study the other day I don't
know if that's true but that's what I
heard on the television but one of the
things one of the things most people
don't know that phytoplankton
contributes to 70% of the oxygenation of
the earth period and rainforests are
closer to 30% yeah yeah so I guess
wherever the Corn Belt fits into that
yeah yeah well yeah there's more than
one rainforest in the Amazon though yeah
trees in general 30% yeah exactly and
Corn Belt how many corn belts are there
yeah but the ocean the reason why I
think a big reason why is because the
70% of the dam surface as well yeah but
no the I think the kids are the one of
the most and repr sent of our body is
water as well just very interesting yeah
yeah when you get into these you know
sacred metrics but I think that when you
when you educate the children about
these things and show them that there
are solutions and children come up with
great ideas you know put the challenges
out to kids and see what what ideas come
up with you know they're they're pretty
substantial but by teaching the children
I feel like they'll bring it home to
that parents and then the parents will
adapt it rather than if if I start you
know trying to educate an adult about
what I'm doing sometimes they just shut
off but in order to get the kid to
become aware about the tree planting kit
usually has to come through their
parents that then get the kit to the kid
or the teacher that
you can take the kids out to 30 kids at
a time as if the teachers go out with 30
kids at a time with tree planting kits
and they take photos and they send the
photos to their parents and the parents
are like oh wow it's interesting stuff
like that that's that's good stuff
because I think like as you keep talking
about kids it keeps keeps really forming
more and more in my head because I'm
writing a lot about kids right now I'm
writing a lot about time right now and
one of the most important things that we
can do with time is we have to teach
kids about time because when children
learn about time and they learn about
the quality of knowledge that they can
fill themselves with in the short time
that they have when they're young that
gives them some really great foundation
to build the rest of their life on and
actually compounds that knowledge and
those processes so it would compound
further if the kids were to plant trees
if they were to understand more about
ecosystem sustainability I think - I
think going on a tour - Recology which
is our waste recycling compost Center in
San Francisco was one of the most
awareness expanding experiences I've
ever had in my life one of the top for
sure and I think most people would never
you know think that I went there and
I've also been to a slaughterhouse as
well and these experiences were very
very at a young age were very very
enriching for me to just better
understand about you know how how things
work yeah so you mentioned a lot there
about education children and time and I
was mentioned - this new - this earlier
that I was with my my son over the
weekend
he's 14 now I have a 14 an 8 year old
and we we had a moment together where he
expressed some that he was upset with me
for not spending as much time
with him and spending too much time on
on my work and even kind of mocked it
and called it yeah I'm not like you I'm
a all Green PC and and you know one of
the one with the earthy you know and I
respect that I don't try to push my my
my beliefs my values on my son I expose
it to him but but in that conversation
he said why even doing this the
scientists are stating that it's it's
too late that were past the tipping
point and that's a whole generation now
of kids that are growing up with the
potential of having a planet that's not
inhabitable in that I don't think that's
okay the imagine we were left out we
would be pissed yeah yeah and then we
could be are part of that we all I mean
it's still in our times timelines you
know like by 20 what would we say that
this is a product mostly of the
Industrial Revolution yes so there's a
song by Julian Casablancas that it goes
something like this that we were when we
went to school we were taught everything
about economic war and how mother nature
can give us what we need and then
explain the factories and the pollution
on the street and I feel that we have
been tricked that we are separate from
nature and we need to work on only
feeding the economy even when you look
at politics today majority of of the
talk about is the economy and where's
the ecology you know in it and if we
like I mentioned before we can create
numerous types of jobs around taking
care of the earth and cleaning up our
mess
there's limitless jobs with which we can
we can think of and create solutions
towards and create artificial
intelligence and robotics that can help
us with that process as well I can
augment our earth in that sense yeah I
remember five years ago or so when I was
also studying politics and economics and
greater depth
the right when I was first moving the
Bay Area I was very mind blown about how
I think it was really when I was
starting to tap into the word ecology
mmm because I was tapping into the word
ecology and I realized that economics
take such precedence over ecology that
that's one of the reasons why the earth
is losing its sustainability and having
its health bar deplete a little bit
although one does need to be nuanced in
the discussion and say that the
Industrial Revolution and the technology
age that we live in now has enabled us
amazing things and so as we do stay
nuanced to mention that it's been
incredible at the same time if ecology
is gonna take a backseat then we're
gonna continue seeing problems so
economics and ecology can live
harmoniously together we just got to
figure out exactly how to do that in Wu
ji is kind of one of the things that
enables us to do so I'm glad we've
touched on kids so much
my glad you brought up your story as
well because we do not want generations
of kids being hopeless about about the
future and okay let's ask I mean this is
this is probably a good good question
for you what are your favorite sources
of alternative energy good question so I
have a couple of partners that are
working on that this guy one partner
count is that like dozen one is with
Tesla sustainable villages it's actually
a descendant of Nikola Tesla the great
great nephew which Nikola Tesla is
probably one of my favorite past
geniuses and when I got into the whole
sustainability world and curiosity one
of the things that sparked my media to
want to make it change as I read about
25 books of the past greatest minds that
left a lasting impact on this earth
whether it be da Vinci or Einstein or
Tesla
franklin and Nikola Tesla was one of the
most intriguing and innovative and he
shared his ideas freely - he didn't
eaten all of his patents he shared and
they asked him you know don't you care
that people steal your ideas needs to
know I care that they don't have any of
their own and I thought that was
brilliant but so they got a technology
around hydropower which is an old old
technology but it's a pretty simple
concept these Osia these rivers flow
constantly and if you can put a turbine
on the rivers that only improve the
ecosystems not not our detriment to it I
help with flooding and even up collect
plastics out of the river ways and you
know there's 80% of the oceans plastic
comes from ten rivers on this planet
eighty percent of the oceans Plastics
comes from ten percent of the rivers and
ten rivers comes from ten not even 10
percent ten rivers yeah damn this is the
Pareto distribution at work hydro dams
also can collect the plastic along those
10% and then that times rivers what do
you know which reverse those are we do I
don't know but which can give us one or
two Ganges the the Rio Grande the Amazon
yeah and the biggest populations along
them so imagine if you can put these
Boyan involved Lancelot I don't know him
the ocean cleanup project okay yeah yeah
yeah you know yeah why is he not on
those rivers because that would be his
good place yeah well if one of my other
people I'm working with this plastic
bank and he's got a TED talk where it
says cleaning up the oceans is the the
wrong way to do it
it's like walking into your house and
it's overflowing with water and the
faucets running and you grab a mop and
start trying to clean up the mess
instead of shutting off the water you
have to shut the water first otherwise
it's gonna be an endless mess so we have
to stop the plastic from getting to the
oceans before before we
it up but so imagine we could put these
hydro dams along the river ways to clean
up the plastics create clean energy
along the way and then mind you these
plastic is just comes from oil which can
also be converted into an energy source
Ora or building resource as well but so
that's one of my favorite energies
because it just uses the natural power
from the earth like wind yeah when is uh
you look at the the total effect of it
of having to build these giant turbines
and then ship them to the site and then
put them up there it's not that much of
a net benefit when you look at all can
we argue and say that the same thing is
that you have to build the dam that you
have to organic local material that you
can build and you also have to have a
grid as well to move the energy from the
hydropower to well
well ideally we could get to you know
zero point energy at some point you know
Gates wrote about that like two years
ago or something like that I thought
that was fantastic
we just got we've just got to get to
that point an exercise my way I think we
are gonna flourish with flying colors
when energy is costs nothing and is
completely carbon positive even like oh
my that's what Nikola Tesla was working
on you know for four years I remember
that meme that I saw that if the
Rothschilds bloodline was replaced with
the Tesla's and it was like just this
massive utopic technologically advanced
civilization that didn't look like it
had any suffering yeah I think we're
going to I think I think so too
there's a and there's one more
technology I like it's from a there's a
couple of groups working on that one of
them's be an LC II when was that Sam for
I don't know I met them at the World
Economic Forum but they have these these
energy generators that have built to go
in shipping containers and they create
energy at a biomass
food waste human waste trees plants they
also can they have ones for plastics so
container and then we're putting it in
the place in a place and it could even
go in the bottom of like a building yeah
yeah like a big condo tower or at a
festival or wherever already yeah
exactly and even at these eco hubs these
impact hubs so all the and we're working
out a partnership with them so when
we're planting trees on these areas and
anytime the trees die or the natural
vegetation you know it needs to be
cleaned up we can put them into the
energy generating machines and then
create a ton of energy and they also
create graphene too and they create like
bio pellets and graphene graphene yeah
yeah so these machines building for
building material building yeah you can
I mean if you haven't looked at graphene
yet it's probably one of the coolest
materials that are going to transform
our world and in many different ways
it's a great conductor of electricity as
well yeah yeah yeah there's a comes from
biomass yeah oh that means carbon so
it's a form of carbon graphene is so you
can use the one of these machines can
create a ton of it a day and there's uh
there's another group that's creating
these these strands autographing because
graphene just nano graphite they're
creating these strands no graphite yeah
and they're creating these strands and
they're gonna they're looking to put
them into the earth where it gets hot
and it can take that energy from the
earth and bring it to the surface with
like no energy loss and then that that's
that's that's the thermal energy from
the core of the earth yeah damn and
that's hella abundant and that's great
because what is going on in the core of
the earth I relate to frequently as the
what's going on in the Sun and this in
our star and if we could just figure out
how to harness the power of the harness
the power of the star similar to that I
was just brushing your heads
yes okay great so this is this has been
amazing I think this has been very
in-depth sustainability regeneration of
our ecosystem prioritizing ecology
alongside economics expanding the minds
of children into the understanding
regenerative energy and leaving a better
and brighter world moving forward into
into the future wuji with the rideshare
with the coin and with the impact hubs
hell yes
and if we're wrapping this up here I'll
share with you what would you means and
how I came up with the idea please
my buddy went off to be a monk about
five years ago and he came back about
two years ago and for a couple of weeks
and he taught me Qigong and the first
stance and Qigong is a woodsy stance and
you stand with your feet about shoulders
width apart and you focus on your energy
and the bubbling well it's like the
center of your foot right right behind
the balls of your feet and you kind of
rock back and forth and you get in the
mooji stance and it's very grounding and
you even imagine your feet like roots
into the ground and i'll like the
negative energy goes out through the
roots and then all the positive energy
feels feels even I love that practice
that's a really good one energetic
Ivor's that with as their onboarding
this this grounded stance that they can
they can always find whenever they're
having a tough time it happens a lot in
traffic so it's on yeah yeah yeah so
yeah our whole idea with the the drivers
are going to go through a whole
mindfulness training as part of this of
their onboarding process so the customer
service and the happiness and like I
feel like the the vibes Tesla said if
you want to find out the secrets of the
universe focus on energy vibration and
frequency so we're looking to have raise
the vibes within every Ryne because I
feel like if you smile at me on the
street and if I'm having a bad day I
could totally change my day butterfly
yeah and then you could have 10 other
people that are
we're looking to do that with with the
right sir but the right frequency and
vibration yeah and the right share was
initially called G ride and good ride
yeah green ride yeah exactly
and we were trying to rebrand it about
about ten months ago and I was showing
one of my buddies the wuji stance and he
knew we were trying to rename it yeah
and he's they call it that and we we
played with it for about a month or two
and I finally looked up the the meaning
of bougie and it comes from the
daodejing
and woody means limitless stillness and
the universe before the Big Bang was in
a woody state so midlist still build
this yeah so that's what Jean that's
definitely a great brand for this yeah
yeah I loved learning about the story
and more depth I hope you guys did as
well this has been an absolute blast
Stephen thanks for coming out of the
show my brother much love god speed with
everything we will definitely continue
being a an ecological contributor to the
success and I hope you guys do too if
you guys had a good time definitely take
this content and go and talk to two
other people about it have them talk to
two other people about it let's get more
people talking about ecology and
sustainability renewables regeneration
of Earth and prospering let's do it and
also subscribe comment below with your
thoughts don't just consume this content
go create with it go write about it make
a video about it start your own green or
with it let's go let's build let's
create and join us on patreon we got we
have wuji's links below definitely check
them out join us on patreon
we need continued sustaining this
growing it impacting more people so join
us let's do it together much love
everyone peace